okay so the divorce says the marriage
laws discriminate against men so when
men have you ever heard the phrase it's
cheaper to keep her happy wife happy
life yes so so basically there's a lot
of men that are really tired of the
women leaving taking their kids and
taking their money I'll give you a
couple stats like um women only get
custody or men only get custody 10 20 of
the time
um because the courts favor the women
why did I do that uh well there's a
couple reasons one is that the way men
typically pay more right yeah and I I
think they should be rewarded for that
however the the way that the courts do
it is if you make more money and the the
wife spends more time with the kids we
should award the wife custody so it's
kind of like a gotcha moment where it's
like he's doing the right thing right
he's working yeah and paying for his
kids and he's he's punished for it
doesn't make sense